here's a story you may have heard
something about this this is the latest
from the new york post it says a
transgender cheerleader kicked out of a
texas college for allegedly choking a
teammate
denies that there was any physical
altercation and intends to sue actually
avery chanel medlock
insisted
okay we've got the pronoun issue here as
it's written so i'm going to try to
correct it as we go along um avery
chanel medlock 25 insisted his side of
the story wasn't heard before he was
slapped with a 500 criminal citation
and kicked off of the cheer team for
allegedly assaulting another cheerleader
on july 24th at
ranger college medlock told the post
there was no physical contact at all i
was just trying to talk it out as an
adult medlock whose legal name is avery
chanel satchel
claims that teammate carly jones got
upset
when
she refused to buy her a vape
with the way pronunciation
or switched around i'm this gets even
more confusing
so who was
who refused to buy who a vape i don't
even know now medlock later went to
carly's room to apologize but an
argument ensued rather than an assault
as alleged
medlock's teammate then called her
father who called the police the athlete
said that she was then escorted off of
university grounds and booted from
ranger college cheer team she isn't he
the guy okay it's just
it makes it impossible to understand
anything of course uh when we're doing
this pronoun thing
uh messages seeking comment from ranger
college cheerleading coach nicholas
turner university officials were not
immediately returned
medlock says if i would have assaulted
her i'd be in jail
um and yet the police say that there was
an assault
okay so that's the story is that that
was originally a story that this
cheerleader who is who is a a male
but identifies as a female is on the
cheerleading squad uh physically
assaulted in fact choked
a an actual female on the team and the
original story was that he reacted that
way because the female
said you know remarked about the fact
that he has a penis and therefore isn't
a woman and he responded violently the
father was called the police were called
the police say that there was an assault
that occurred
and um even though they're just slapping
the assailant with a minor fine about
you know about on par with what you get
for a parking violation but the assault
did happen
now he's coming out and saying oh no it
never happened at all
a couple of points here first of all i'm
going to put some of the the pictures up
on the screen
that are in the new york post article
and we've seen and any time this story
comes up on social media these are the
pictures attached to it
and you can see this is the the trans
cheerleader
and you can see
okay there's another one there
just filtered and photoshopped to death
look this one right here is come on
it looks like he it looks like he peeled
off somebody else's face and put it on
um when you
when you have to do that
okay then maybe that should tell you
something
like the pictures that are being
circulated of this guy are
these are not pictures these are cartoon
drawings that's not what he looks like
at all
but also maybe more importantly the
violence is not a surprise at all
as the existence of men in these spaces
in women's sports and women's bathrooms
men claiming the label of womanhood for
themselves in any context at all
you know this is a form of violence
already i'm going to use the left's
framing against it here because they
like to say that everything is violence
speech is violence silence is violence
uh sometimes violence though isn't
violence
but everything else is violence
well i would say that this is violence
even before you get to the physical
assault before the physical assault
happens it is violence because
when men intrude into these spaces and
they appropriate female identities
it is an invasion it's an intrusion it
is a robbery stealing privacy stealing a
woman's identity stealing opportunities
all of that and it comes with an
implicit and often explicit threat
of social shaming of loss of job loss of
status
you know if you if a woman protests it
so when the man shows up whether he says
it out loud or not and oftentimes he
does say it out loud but even if he
doesn't the the implied threat to all of
the women
is that you better go along with this
you better let them into your spaces you
better you better sacrifice
privacy on the altar of uh of this man's
ego and if you don't bad things are
gonna happen to you
so that is violence in and of itself
and then it shouldn't be a surprise when
you have this
sort of
implied threat
that always accompanies the man as he
enters into these female spaces it
shouldn't be a surprise when he actually
lashes out violently
and in particular because of the uh
because of the sense of entitlement
that's that's encouraged
i mean these guys have already been told
by society you can do whatever you want
the only thing that matters
is your comfort level the only thing
that matters
is how you feel that's all that matters
that should be your number one number
two one through ten list of priorities
it's all about you
and so you
put all those things together and you
have a recipe for actual physical
violence against women so this is not a
surprise at all
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts